[Applause]
I didn't actually expect to be in
Asheville for the first time in my life
until three weeks from now
when my son is getting married
here. [Applause]
[Applause]
Thank you. He's marrying a ?Nashville? girl. [Applause]
[Applause] And it was
because of my son, whose name is Mike,
or Michael. Or Mikey. Depending on
what time period we're talking about.
It was because of him that I discovered what an
incredible disappointment I had been to my father.
And it
was almost entirely the fault of the Mighty
Ducks. [Laughter]
Because shortly after we moved to America,
to the frozen Midwest, um,
Mike, was Mikey then, um, went to see the Mikey- Mighty
Mighty Ducks and came back saying, "I have to play hockey. I have to do this."
I have to play hockey, I have to do this, I'm gonna do this. And he did.
He learned to play hockey, he learned to ice skate. Next thing
you know, I was a hockey
dad. [Laughter]
I was
a good hockey dad in that I could drive him to hockey. And I could
stand in a cold
shed. After that I kind of failed
as a hockey dad.
I was never quite sure what was happening.
Um, he actually asked me, after my first attempt to cheer him on, to either stop
cheering him
on, or to get the terminology
right. It wasn't a hockey
bat. I'm shouting, "Hit that flat thing,"
was just wrong.
And I apologized and, and, was sort of silent after that, and was never quite sure what was happening but I
would keep my eye on the score. And I would know which side was him and which side was the other team.
So at the end
of the game I would be able to say, "Well you did
best, or, or, or congratulations
[Laughter]. And then, my father came out
from England to stay with us for a few days. And I took him
with. To a hockey match. And I got to
see the joy. In my dad's face. Watching
his grandson. Part of his genetic line. Play
a sport. [Laughter]
And
play well and take pride in this and, I saw
this amazing
amazing joy and delight in my dad's eyes I'd
never ever seen. I was,
the other kind of kid.
Um, in, in sort of, Junior School where you get two team captains. And they get to
pick the kids that they wanted to play with them, and
they pick backwards and forwards. They would eventually get
down
to a very short girl with very thick glasses and a leg brace
and
me. [Laughter]
And then they'd pick her. [Laughter]
I did not have what it took to play sports. I had
a different kind of head. And it wasn't that I didn't want to be good at sports, I would
have loved to have been good at sports. Um. I would go out onto
that football field, or the rugby
field, or whatever the kind of field it was, with every intention
of making everybody proud of me and they would tell me where to go and stand I would go and stand there and I'd watch
that ball go. And I'd think you know, that ball it's a lot like those
adverts in the back of those American comics
for, baseballs that you can throw and they, they go in all sorts of weird
directions, and
that's really cool
and, you know that, that's not quite as cool
though as those x-ray spectacles that they advertise,
where you can not only look at your hand and see the bones, but you can
also see naked ladies! [laughter]
And
it's one dollar ninety-nine, and the Americans have to be so far ahead of
us
technologically. [Laughter]
And they have sea monkeys. And I don't know what
they are but they're monkeys, and they live under the water. And somehow,
the older male sea monkeys can smoke pipes.
- underwater, and I wonder
how you smoke a pipe underwater, and just as I'm pondering
the various ways you could smoke a pipe underwater, something very large and heavy and wet and made
of leather is gonna hit me in the side of the face. And then I'm gonna look 'round and people are going
to be shouting at me because apparently I should have known this was going to
happen and done something about it
and... That was how I played sports.
What
I did was make things up.
It was all I really wanted to do. Um,
my dad found this rather hard to understand that I had no wish to follow him in into
any of the family businesses that he wanted to be in or he was in, I, I,
didn't have that. I didn't want to be in property.
I told him I wanted to write. So he tried to get me a job
as somebody who showed people around a show
home. And I said, "that's not actually writing". And he said, "no, no, no,
"No, no, no. There's a lot of time when people won't be visiting the show home, so you can just sit there and
write."
And to please him I actually went for an interview, but the man never showed up.
So I got on a bus and went home and that was the end of my attempt to ever get a real
job. [Laughter]
And I wrote, and my dad was great. He was really supportive
in the ways that he could be supportive when I, when I was a, a young
starving journalist with two
very small kids, he suggested that, um, probably the
best thing that he could do was he had a flat that he owned above a shop. And
I could just stay. We could stay in that flat, and we
could cover the bills but we didn't actually have to pay rent, and that was great.
And eighteen months later, when I could afford to pay rent he said, "Right, now move out!"
"Go get a place." And I did. And it was great.
And time went
by and I started, to get more and
more successful. I started to win awards.
And people would say to my dad, "You must be so proud of him."
And he'd say, "I'm proud of all my children."
Until my little sister told him to stop saying that 'cause it was really irritating.
And I was proud too, Mike, grew up.
And he started doing computer things. And I discovered
whenever I'd ask him what it was that he actually did,
that it all went away. I'd say, What do you do? and he'd say, Well
what I'm doing right now is
?wah wah wah wah wah wah?
?wah?." "I don't think I got that." And he said, "Well you understand, Python is a programming language."
language," and,"I'd yes I've got that," and he'd say, "Well ?wah wah wah wah?
?wah wah wah wah wah?."
And it was 2009,
and I'd written a book called "Blueberry Girl." Which was
illustrated, and beautifully illustrated by Charles Vess.
And the last time I'd done a signing in New York, it had been a horror show.
It had been at Barnes and Noble Union Square. It had been at night.
Um, there was, we had to finish signing
for about a thousand people against the clock, and all I did was put my head down and I signed.
And I signed and we checked, and we were pleading with these people keep the store open and we finished, and the last person
went out and they locked the doors. And I swore I was never coming back. And now I was coming back,
but I was coming back to a bookstore called Books of Wonder, a beautiful children's store,
and Charles Vess was there with me and the smartest thing we did
was we were gonna start at one o'clock in the afternoon. So we didn't have a curfew.
We were great. And I was in the taxi on the
way to the signing when my phone rang and
I answered it, and it was my sister, my little sister,
calling from England to let me know that my dad had been in a business
meeting and he'd asked for a glass of water because he wasn't feeling very well.
And having never been sick for a day in his life, he was dead of a heart attack by
the time he got to the
hospital.
And I was numb. I had the taxi drop me off.
Actually in Union Square near that Barnes and Noble and I, I,
phoned my children. Phoned a
few people and
then, my agent ?Marilee? who was with me said,
"You could not do this, you know, everyone will understand." And I said no,
I, I actually really want to do this."And I walked
up to Books of Wonder. And Charles was there and Charles
showed them his beautiful paintings and I
read this poem that I'd written to an unborn daughter.
And then I signed for fifteen hundred
people - for 8 and a half hours.
And it was wonderful. All of these people were there and each person came up gave me something
to do, and I didn't have to think about it, and I didn't have to worry.
And at the end, I was exhausted. And I
was done. And I was leaving
Books
of
Wonder and ?Marilee? said to me, "You know the last time I saw your father?"
And I said, "No, when was the last time you saw my dad?" And she said, "Oh,
"Oh, it was in that Barnes and Noble signing you did in Union
Square," she said, "He came up there. And he was just standing on
the side. He was in New York and he stood on the side and he watched you and
I saw him and I recognised him and I went over and I said, 'Hello David.' And he said 'hello.'
And I said 'You must be so proud of Neil,' and he said 'I really am.'
And she said, "So I said to him, 'But you must have known this would happen.
You must have known he's, he's such a brilliant writer. He's, he's wonderful. You must have
known this was gonna happen.' And my dad
looked at her and he said, 'No, he wanted to be a writer. I thought I was going to be supporting him his whole life.'
[laughter] And I
thought, you know for my dad, watching me signing at that Barnes
and Noble was probably an awful lot like me
watching Mike play hockey.
I
thought, but even so he was perfectly willing to support me my
entire life. Just as I would have been willing to support Mike.
And even though he was completely baffled, just as I had been
baffled, he watched, as I watched,
with every bit as much love.
[Applause]